like people will say they're like women
will rape themselves I'm an eight or a
nine you're like man please like by
definition there can't be that many age
for nines and there's be some ugly
broads talking about the eight or nine I
like please but being a five I'd say
five and six is fantastic
that's fine for for most guys a five or
six perfect now when you did below below
five you're talking about undercover or
night practice
50 year old women practice and by virtue
of being 50 you are not a nine you don't
even qualify past the five
once you're 40 really as a woman there's
no way you're above a five
yeah
yeah like biologically you can't hit
like so that's a point
you know you mentally unstable that's a
point you're delusional that's a point
and then go on the looks point you got
another man's kid
Point you're just going down the rung
yeah how many points okay if a girl's a
10 yeah she bought she's a kid what is
she what is she she's the four four six
points
like if you're talking about
marriageable
um
she's a 10 but but she slept with 20
guys
30 guys yeah she's a 10. I would give
her eight she might be good at it
eight or nine she might be good at
sleeping with me and I might want to get
work yeah
oh for a girlfriend
oh I see I thought I was just practicing
no no she's a 10 but she's what slept
with 30 men oh girlfriend style oh damn
30 men I'll give her a seven
tins are rare
but we also have to know she probably
slept with men for money and old men and
sugar daddies and [ __ ] like that so and
NFL players so yeah
I thought you'd do more actually I
thought three three uh three I was like
I was like so these women got 30 bodies
ugly ass chicks got 30 bodies so what we
doing
and and women that are nines and tens
they're basically in the model category
so they're hookers essentially they've
been belonged to the market they've been
transacted directly for money in various
ways modeling
they've used their looks and body to
transact that's definitional hooker so
if she's an Instagram model she's a
hooker
she's just an e-hooker okay so that's a
transaction
okay
okay or she has her only fans he's a
hooker right so at that particular Point
nines attends tend to have been
transacted themselves they've had sugar
daddies they've been flowing out they
had newspaper tuition she been a model
she was a spokesperson she's a fitness
trainer slash these are e hookers so
this is what I consider nines and tens
ion I still bro I'll still practice with
them and they might be a part of my
concubine now Harem but yeah but they
ain't getting wife yeah yeah no wifing
material yes so then okay so she's a 10
but
she's got an attitude I can't deal with
women with attitudes
um is she snarky or sarcastic she's a 10
yeah that's gonna be like a seven I'll
give you give you a second
okay so it's interesting the the body
count and the attitude it's like the
same yeah
yeah well those things are qualities
that women think are endearing
like uh now they're like oh God guys
want me and uh and if they're snarky and
all that stuff the attitude stuff and
and that I don't deal with that very
well actually I've developed a second
archetype of people on the shows so
there's a type of guy that kind of likes
girls that are mean to him I don't know
what I don't know what it is but and
like guys guys will say okay this is
manosphere we'll be like no no we want
fit feminine friendly and I'm like okay
healthy man maybe but I'm like there's a
portion of men that like girls that are
mean to them and I can't explain it but
I've seen the archetype because it's
like I'll see the guy he's got options
he's a good looking you know it I don't
know is she attractive though what is
the woman attractive with the attitude
oh there you that's why that's that
that's why there's a donut the attitude
that he could certainly date yeah
you're saying they're pretty the girls
that he can date that are pretty and he
don't want I I don't disagree with you I
don't disagree with you I think I think
you're I think men do typically go
afterwards a lot of times like they
didn't have like a dad like I've just
noticed that a lot of times they don't
have like those guys they don't have a
dad and so it's like they kind of look
for their mother I think I think this is
like my woman's interpretation of it
could be I don't yeah it's just an
archetype I've seen it over and over
there's guys that yeah I mean but these
are younger guys right yeah okay I was
gonna say yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
exactly it gets old younger guys are
typically that's something or maybe the
girl's like a predator and he's just
like I don't know
I think the girl knows how to manipulate
him and make him feel good when he's
like when when she's with him yeah he's
like this is Euphoria same thing with
women and then when it's bad he's like
yeah but she makes me feel good you know
what I mean she tickles his balls just
right so he's like there's nobody that
does that and so I need to keep her like
that so yeah and then if she's
attractive he'll put over more [ __ ]
I always tell guys get you a six
six aim for sixes okay they be out here
in these streets too but six sixes sixes
one out of seven yeah um why not a seven
let's break down the girls fight by
Rings yeah it gets tough you know
standard of beauty but ten nine and ten
belong to the marketplace they will be
transacted amongst men in a variety of
ways yes some web some of them will
become wives and hot soccer moms right
and you're like damn that doctor but the
only reason why she's with him he's a
doctor right but that doctor has the
Super trophy wife that's what hot girls
become you know very attractive women
become they become transacted Suburban
wives so seven and eights eights or want
to be nines watch out for eight
so eights don't have it what it takes
they might be one to be a model but
they're five three you know what I mean
like they they want to be a supermodel
when they but they're short you know
what I mean but they're still attractive
it's like they could maybe get a low
level modeling contract it's low level
you ain't getting you ain't cat walking
you ain't getting the runway but she
lives in Tupelo Mississippi right you
know what I mean and she's like man I'm
gonna go to New Orleans or Dallas and
make it in the big leagues that's a
eight she's a wanna be nine be careful
with them they're tricky they're tricky
they they want to be treated like the
nines and the tens but there's always
going to be she thinks she's gonna get
what the pretty girls that she sees that
are nine to ten slightly more attractive
with her she wants that and she's gonna
keep missing and missing and missing
until she adjusts her idea and uh she's
also not gonna sell herself like the
nine or ten
she's not not gonna stop well she can't
she can't play she's too good for good
for that oh okay okay so the nines are
tons they're like the Nigel tens will be
on First Class getting flown to Aruba
okay right I ain't doing that with that
old man like she's gonna put up a fight
I got two standards right she's gonna
put up a [ __ ] bike right and so
dangerous okay seven sevens kind of
don't exist they muddle you know what I
mean it's kind of a non-existent okay
yeah you're in that the Kevin says like
it's Kevin Sanders so and I have to
agree with him because it's easy to say
everybody's a seven and I actually did
it too but sevens are non-existent it's
a big drop off
sixes are gonna be what people will call
um an adjustable six right she could be
a plain Jane or she could be somebody
who can look like an eight if she tried
um She's Some Girls you might be
surprised she shows at the gym and
you're not you're like who is this and
then she gets dressed and puts her
eyelashes on and [ __ ] you're like wow
she's a knockout she's an eight so a six
can jump up in that eight territory but
she has a right mind she might have very
abilities in the city that's what I've
noticed like the people will call it
like two sixes can be completely
different it looks like one will be a
lot cuter but they're still sexy they're
still the Silver Six they could be
something wrong they build awkward yeah
let's not let's not get cocky Deborah
six is better than all day plays yeah
they do though and they should they
should know their place a six can also
be an eight that came down to six things
right she was she was hot she gained a
little weight she partied and [ __ ] she
got the raspy voice she smoked
cigarettes now oh damn she used to be
good and she aged yes outdoor you know
yeah I'll take her
so the sixes are in a weird territory
right like they're they're they were
they could be like a we called a late
developer a late bloomer where she was
ugly as hell until her senior year and
then she showed up all developed and she
know how to put her makeup on you're
like oh you know what I mean like so a
six could be that's a six I always say
that's where you should aim because
that's where you're gonna have your most
success it's not aiming low though
five you still all right okay you know a
lot of fives get married
a lot of fives you see a woman she built
like a bowling pin and she could be
married right you can do well but you
better have an attitude if you think you
are a six five six six seven eight nine
and you're a five you're gonna be single
like a mofo you ain't getting yeah no
the five they kind of another place
gotta know your place and you better by
not be holding out here okay there's no
[ __ ] cameras here myself for five for
five they they can't they don't do you
throwing your life away don't be a
single mother don't act like you got
value don't act like you know your worth
you sit your ass down and learn how to
make these tacos you better learn how to
make that hamburger helper you better
know how to cook clean I don't know how
to cook take me I don't fancy dates [ __ ]
yeah no no five so fours once you go
five once you go below five
now you're aiming low
so fours or 49ers
fours are dangerous
because they are fours and they want to
be treated like nines they are
completely delusional really yes we call
them 49ers really wow so a four will be
out of her world delusional okay she
won't try to be a five
she'll be busted and try to be a nine
I'm gonna be an Instagram model and yeah
people will be following her and all
that [ __ ] and she'll you know a four
will be tragic it's a tragic case it's
tragedy
tragedy their attitudes are bad
they wearing hair weave and they're it's
tragedy tragic they're overweight by 200
pounds would you put the average at best
girl I would think I think of her as a
four she would be four yeah because her
attitude was off oh no I'd give her a
four like her face oh she was ugly
but so then she wanted the nine
treatment she was a 49er she's a 49er
she was like I deserve a man that has
this this and this like like how would
you get that guy like you couldn't even
be in the marketplace with that you
could he'll sleep with you right
but you won't be seen with them very
much in public he'll sleep with you
three times and he'll be on you'll be in
a rotation of dudes three threes are
gonna be I mean this is the pit of Hell
once you hit the three two and one I
mean you're talking about you know
chicks homeless whales chicks that
Homeless chicks uh you know you're
dealing with bad ass I mean you're
dealing with women in wheelchairs and
[ __ ] you know I mean like you dealing
with the bottom of the barrel bottom of
the barrel economically they're poor
they come from uh broken homes these are
people who smoke and they smoke do drugs
we they're completely pretty much
incapacitated
untouchable
men who mess with threes twos and ones
you're scraping the bottom of the barrel
and typically STI
they're gonna throw bricks through your
window they're untrained untrainable
ugly have you ever slept with the three
tour one
um
I've been around the block I've been
around here I know but
um I mess with some scapulin skeezers in
my time you know I had to I had to do
what I had to do you know but uh as you
say men will screw anything but uh yeah
man I learned nothing I just thought
four was like the bot no or it's not the
bottom because no Four's not the bottom
because I mean five
um yeah they don't have to be obese
there's a lot of skinny knock me trailer
park pieces of trash I mean there's a
you don't have to be fat
fatness is never prosperous so that's
three two are ones I know are like obese
that's a quality yes but but you there's
some other people who are three twos and
ones that like like she's a mental case
right like you know she crazy yeah
that's a three oh okay I thought we were
going off of looks oh okay okay
um
okay yeah I mean fat you don't have to
be fat but yeah fat women are going to
be good
but not necessarily five five and below
so that's single mothers single mothers
all the way going you see down six
points for me yeah single mothers are
doing as long as she's like a nine or
eight then she's below four yeah you go
yeah you go and you're gonna be super
hot in a single mother like
yeah no man and then yeah you dropping
down like for me to deal with you single
mothers know I mean I'll hang out with
you I'll do all that stuff but you're
never getting a ring never
yeah but you definitely ain't getting
the room yeah
but they might try to believe they're
going to get the ring they might try to
act good for like six months in a day
but I'll show you I'm different
I don't I don't care what you show me
you are not getting the damn thing from
cgn
as many of you know I was just banned on
tick tock
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible